y el pacto en seguridad de eeuu reino
unido y australia se llama a un cus y
tiene como principal propósito
contrarrestar la influencia de china en
la región indo-pacífico su primera
iniciativa será dotar a australia de una
nueva flota de submarinos que
funcionarán a base de propulsión nuclear
y no con la tecnología dice la eléctrica
que han venido funcionando hasta ahora
es un cambio grande en la política
exterior de australia en su política
militar y de hecho se va a utilizar
información secreta reservada de eeuu
para fabricar esta nueva flota de
submarinos el primer ministro de
australia scott morrison ha explicado
que esto nada tiene que ver con
armamento nuclear que los submarinos no
tendrán armas nucleares y que bajo
ninguna circunstancia australia está
iniciando una campaña de armamento
nuclear pero empieza entonces una nueva
fase en la política exterior y de
seguridad por parte del reino unido
estados unidos y australia puntualmente
en la región incapacitado